es geht um politische phrasen es ist
eine ganz besonders die im endeffekt in
keiner politischen talkshow fehlt es ist
immer so dass mindestens einer der
anwesenden politikerinnen oder
politikern irgendwann im laufe einer
solchen sendung von den menschen da
draußen spricht und das feld immer so
beiläufig aber ich glaube dass diese
diese begrifflichkeit die menschen da
draußen ein symptom eines sehr großen
problems ist wenn ein politiker von den
menschen da draußen spricht dann heißt
es ja dass er sich selbst drinnen geht
in etwa sieht in einem ausgewählten
kreis und auf das gemeine fußvolk schaut
das regiert das bei laune gehalten
werden muss und ich halte das aus zwei
gründen für problematisches eine ist das
ist ein extrem falsches und auch der
mittelalterliches selbstbild des
politikers du als politiker bist kein
regent du hast auch kein
paternalistisches verantwortungsgefühl
den menschen gegenüber zu haben sondern
diese menschen da draußen
das sind ja eigentlich deine bosse das
sind gewissermaßen seine auftraggeber
durch deren stellvertreter für die
politik machen muss und ich glaube
dadurch das so oft diese rhetorische
mauer aufgebaut wird zwischen wir
politiker und die menschen da draußen
und man wird mit diesem begriff ja auch
immer ironischerweise volksnähe
suggerieren da so eine lücke entsteht
die daten genau die stoßen können die
ohnehin schon stichwort corona pandemie
und querdenker etc die ohnehin schon
seit monaten diese delegitimierung
kampagnen gegen eine liberale demokratie
und auch gegen den rechtsstaat fahren
und deswegen würde ich mir wünschen das
ist vielleicht als kill jedes sich die
akteurinnen und akteure in der politik
einfach mal schütteln und sich auch ein
wenig in demut üben gegenüber den
bürgerinnen und aber ich glaube die
konsequenz ist ansonsten nicht nur
politiker verdrossenheit und
und sinkende wahlbeteiligung sondern
eben dass sich dieser graben immer
weiter auftut und in diese lücke dann
genau die straßen wieder eigentlich
nichts verloren das ist hochinteressant
da alle dass wir eine phrase jetzt leben
sie frieren denn ich glaube die
politiker hören sich meistens selber gar
nicht sprechen und versuchen nur phrasen
zu reden weil sie nicht weil sie
versuchen sagen wir alle aller olaf
scholz möglichst ohne irgendeine aussage
die ich durch ihn durchs leben zu kommen
denn es gibt doch ein bisschen mit dann
uns wenn wir sie mal in einer aussage
treffen dann fallen wir natürlich über
die herbert was anders ist hat ihn
interessant was du gesagt dass ich die
phrasen du sprichst du schaust die
phrase mal genauer an von denen die
politiker wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr
an was sie damit sagen wir da drin wir
da draußen ich glaube diese
abgehobenheit von der du da sprichst
diesen diese distanz die dahin die dort
zutage tritt das ist nicht nur ein
problem der politik sondern das ist ein
problem auch von journalisten die
schnell das ist ein problem von uns
großstadtmenschen gegenüber den menschen
auf dem land und bin ich in der bild
zeitungsredaktion sitze und ich habe
leute leute um mich herum die im
prenzlauer berg und in charlottenburg im
modernen wohnungen leben und moderne
ansichten haben denke ich mir immer
wieder etwas auf denke an die die im
paradis arbeit außerhalb von paderborn
und wald außerdem von altötting und wald
aber weit außerhalb von weise sankt
peter ording leben das sind menschen die
vollkommen anders ticken zum teil als
wir als wir ihn in der großstadt und die
über manche dinge die wir in der
großstadt schon längst konsens haben
als in einer anderen sprache miteinander
reden die haben damit überhaupt nichts
mehr zu tun ja die politikverdrossenheit
ist übrigen stärker ja die distanz
zwischen politikern und menschen wird
größer aber es ist nicht nur ein problem
der politik ja es kommt auch nicht von
ungefähr also ich
menschen sind menschen entfremden sich
nicht von systemen menschen entfremden
sich nicht von der demokratie und auch
nicht der politik sondern von politikern
von männern und frauen ob aus der elite
ob es jetzt polit da sind oder
journalistinnen und journalisten wie wir
hier sitzen oder andere lobby bosse wie
auch immer dass ich einfach nur sagen
will und das hast du eben gesagt hat
dass die politiker ja gar keine ahnung
haben was sie da eigentlich erzählen und
sich nicht zu hören das ist ja wohl das
allergrößte armutszeugnis denn ich
glaube sprache zeigt nicht nur
wirklichkeit sondern sie schafft auch
wirklichkeit und noch viel schlimmer sie
verstärkt wirklichkeit um diese tendenz
der
demokratie kritik die haben wir ohnehin
schon und deswegen würde ich mir einfach
wünsche dass gerade in dieser heißen
wahlkampfphase gerade jetzt wo diese
wirklich wirklich wichtige
bundestagswahl ansteht sich alle mal
kurz zusammenreißen und mal zu überlegen
was erzähle ich hier eigentlich aber es
liegt nicht an unserem publikum offenbar
wenn jemand sich irgend eine klare
aussage macht scheuen die leute davon ab
wieder hatte das haben doch alle dass
wir nie sagen würde denen würde ich
sofort aber draußen aber hinzu von
phrasen reden habt ihr habt doch alle
das tri l gesehen aber dem trainer hat
doch jeder versucht möglichst keine
aussage zu machen jeder versucht also
beim fußball würde man sagen die haben
alle in der defensive gespielt bis er
aus bis auf einen der ist bisschen mehr
offensive gegangen und hat sofort das
über den deckel bekommen weil sie eine
meinung seine meinung quoten ging noch
nach unten robert gewonnen der der am
allerwenigsten gesagt aber ich
eigentlich haben wir ja ein ganz tolles
system in deutschland die abgeordneten
die ja laut grundgesetz artikel 830 nur
ihrem gewissen verpflichtet sind die
sind ja eigentlich genau dafür da es
gibt sie überall im ganzen land in jedem
wahlkreis und die müssten eigentlich
jetzt viel stärker auch mal für die
menschen sprechen sie sind ja die
volksvertreter aber leider ist durch
fraktionszwang und durch auch dass die
and personal easy rung der des
politischen betriebs in diesem fall
verschwinden einfach die abgründe sie
verschwinden in ihrer fraktion
parteiendemokratie ist also ich hab ich
auch die familie hatte ich den akteuren
dann werden kannst du dich zu erklären
was ganz so sehen was meinst du mit and
personifizierung ja so man verschwindet
sozusagen in dem was die fraktion will
ja die trauen sich nicht es gibt so
tolle politiker in der spd-fraktion zum
beispiel die längst nicht mit dem ganzen
strom mitschwimmen
aber die höre ich nicht ich höre immer
nur diesen kandidat genau den und ja und
ich habe ihn schon lange machen was alle
schauen am boden aber was sagt der
fraktion sagte fraktions geschäfte was
sowas will gehört werden genau das heißt
die also da nur die mavericks die die
außenseiter die sich die trauen die
kommen halt auch in der
parteiendemokratie sachen alleine
antreten sie sagten menschen entfremdet
sich nicht von demokratie
das würde ich gerne verstehen wollen sie
sagten sie einen fremden sich oder sie
distanzieren sich eher von den personen
die politik machen ich würde da an der
stelle widersprechen wenn ich das gefühl
habe sogar die parteien selbst
entfremden sich meiner ansicht nach von
einer demokratie so wie sie das gerade
ja auch beschrieben haben dass innerhalb
der parteien die sich auch als
demokratische parteien begreifen und das
immer gerne auch betonen im gegensatz zu
der nicht demokratischen partei die
gerade im parlament sitzt aber sich
selbst innerhalb ihrer parteien so
undemokratisch verhalten das brauchen
sie eine aktion der beispiel wo eine
partei sich undemokratische verhalten
hat nun selbst leichter afd eine
realschule also zuletzt ging es um die
wahlen im saarland der grünen als es
darum ging die spitzenkandidaten oder
spitzenkandidatin zu wählen da gab es
einen mann der an die spitze gewählt
wurde aber das war der den grünen nicht
für die grünen nicht richtig weil es
sollte eine frau an der spitze sein also
hat man von berlin aus bestimmt dass das
ganze aufgehoben wird und das sieht
jetzt so ging so weit dass am ende die
stimmen aus dem saarland die grünen
nicht mitzählen ist nur ein beispiel
und auch in den anderen parteien kann
man ich möchte jetzt hier nicht die
grünen nur vorführen hast das anbelangt
da sind die linken und die
sozialdemokraten meiner ansicht nach
auch nicht anders und sogar die cdu also
ich würde in allen parteien sagen ist es
herrscht innerhalb unseres
parteiensystems inzwischen wirklich ein
mangel an gelassen kann direkt hier
antworten sondern auch sagen dann hat
ihren parteien das interessiert mich gar
nicht so sehr weil die sind einfach
damit beschäftigt sich selbst
abzuschaffen und wenn sie dann
irgendwann abgeschafft sind dann ist es
halt der unschuld gewesen das finde ich
jetzt sich so probleme was ich meinte
mitmenschen entfremden sich mich von
demokratie vielleicht stelle ich das
noch mal anders dar wenn ein mann oder
eine frau oder wer auch immer sagt ich
gehe nicht wählen weil ich habe keine
lust mehr auf die demokratie oder ich
fühle mich nicht vertreten oder ich
werde nie wieder an wahlen teilnehmen
oder überhaupt mich engagieren dann wird
das selten daran gelegen haben dass er
sich mit dem system demokratie
auseinander gesetzt hat sich die
strukturen und die prozesse angeguckt
hat und dann gesagt hatten er an den
prozessen will ich mich nicht beteiligen
die sind aus diesen und jenen gründen
nichts für mich sondern das wird immer
daran liegen dass es personen sind sind
die ihn abschrecken die eben entfremden
befremden mit d also die wo so eine
distanz aufgebaut ist wo der einzelne
sagt ich kann mich damit nicht
identifizieren und das meine ich mit
menschen entfremden sich nicht vom
system sondern von anfang an
[Musik]